welcome back before I move on the next
part I just want to make sure I kind of
run sometimes I rush near the end of the
video of this because I want to get
under the the YouTube 10-minute limit
but I just want to make sure you
understand when I the conclusions I
reached in this problem because it's
kind of interesting if I have a bunch of
numbers and when I multiply them I get a
nonzero number I know none of these
numbers can be zero because as you know
if any one of them was zero or maybe
more than one then this value would be
zero so we know none of these can be
zero right are strv and similarly
between s T u and V right let me write
that s T U and V equals zero we know
that at least one of these must be zero
because when you multiply it out you get
zero maybe all of them are well we know
s is not zero because it was up here we
knew T was not zero and we knew V were
not zero because they were all up on
this top one and if any of them were
zero this top equation would have been
zero and that's how we reached that
conclusion so let's let's move on I hope
I'm not confusing you I'm doing it with
a bit of a sense of urgency just because
well I guess one should when taking the
SAT all right number eight during a game
the blue team scored one sixth of its
film easy let me let me do the blue team
in blue blue the blue team scored 1/6 of
his point in first quarter so q1 it
scored 1/6 of points one fourth in the
second quarter
so in q2 it scored 1/4 of its points one
fourth in the second quarter one third
in the third quarter
send q3 it scored one third of its
points one third in the third quarter
and remaining points in the fourth
quarter Q which makes sense right rest
okay in the fourth quarter if the total
score was 36
so total total is 36 36
how many points did the blue team score
in the fourth quarter well the total
points are 36 right so it says it scored
one-sixth in the first quarter so
one-sixth of 36 you could just you know
you could do that in your head or you
could just multiply fractions if you say
1/6 times 36
that equals 36 over 6 which equals 6
right
it scored 6 points in the first quarter
how many score in the second quarter
well what's 1/4 of age well you just
multiply one 1/4 of 36 so you just
multiply one 4 times 36 and you get 9
1/3 of 36 well that's 12 so in the first
three quarters we scored what 6 plus 9
is 15 15 plus 12 is 27 so we scored 27
in the first 3 quarters right and then
we scored the rest in in q4 so it'd be
the total points - what we scored in the
first three quarters which is 27 and 36
minus 27 is 9 points and if I look at
the choices that is choice C and if I
made a mistake is because I cannot add
or multiply add subtract or multiply
fractions but that's all there is to
this problem let's move on now you just
multiply that sometimes I feel like I'm
going too fast so I want to make sure
I'm not I'm not confusing you ok invert
colors I like these time because I don't
have to write a lot or draw well I like
I like the drawing it just takes time I
will switch colors to keep you from
sleeping 2 2 to the 2x this is problem
number 9 problem number 9 2 to the 2x is
equal to 8 to the X minus 1 and they
just want to know what is X so first you
might be confused but the trick to
writing to doing these kind of
exponential I guess we call them an
exponential equation is to get our base
is the same and once we get the base is
the same then we can set the exponents
equal to each other so how do I do that
well can I write 8 as a power of 2 well
sure what's 8 it's 2 to the 3rd power so
let's rewrite 8 as 2 to the 3rd power so
let's figure out the whole thing 2 to
the 2x is 2 to the 2x is equal to
instead of 8 instead of 8 I'm gonna
write 2 to the 3rd power right because
that's all it is and hopefully you can
review the exponent video if you don't
remember that and this 8 is this right
and then that's gonna be to the X minus
1 and then if you remember your exponent
rules and you should remember your
exponent rules before taking the SAT you
know that if you raise something to a
power and then raise that to a power you
can just multiply these two exponents so
that gets us to 2 to the 2x is equal to
2 to the 3 times X minus 1 right then
you distribute the 3 so it's 2 to the 3x
minus 3 right 3 times X 3 times minus 1
3 X minus 3 now 2 to the 2x is equal to
2 to the 3x minus 3 so we know that the
two exponents must be equal to each
other right because we have the same
base so now this just comes the level 1
linear equations problems 2x is equal to
3x minus 3 we can subtract 3x from both
sides and we get minus X is equal to
minus 3 or X is equal to 3 and we are
done and this choice number be turning
the page number 10 image clear image
image invert colors all right
number 10 if for less than I like these
and 4 less than 3 times a certain number
is 2 more than the number what is the
number okay so this is literally treat
turning English into math so I'm gonna
actually write the whole thing you're
not that you should do this on the SAT
because it'll take you too much time but
you can do this kind of with their
written word if for less
then three times a certain number is to
more than the number what is the number
what is number okay so instead of a
certain number I'd like to replace that
with X right just because I'm gonna have
to solve for X so I'm gonna say I'm
gonna change this and I'm gonna say this
is X what is X more than the number X so
now we have if 4 less than 3 times X is
2 more than X what is the number so what
is 4 less than 3 times X 4 less than 3
times X well 3 times X is what it's 3x
all right 3 times X so if I took if I
took this part 3 times X that's 3x and
then 4 less than that for less than that
or less than that it's gonna be minus 4
all right and that is an eye view is you
could view that as equals right you
could have replaced the word equals with
is and it wouldn't have changed it it
wouldn't have changed the meaning of the
Senate so that equals 2 more than the
number or in our case X what is 2 more
than X oh yeah that's X plus 2 2 more
than X you could just rewrite in math as
X plus 2 and then we we solve the
equation so let's see you could add 4 to
both sides you get 3 X is equal to X
plus 6 subtract X from both sides you
get 2x is equal to 6 and divide both
sides by 2 and you get X is equal to 3
and there we go it's a choice you
I will stop this video here because the
next one involves drawing I don't want
to draw on your time I'll see you soon